women turning 30 without a child if
you're childless at 30 at most you've
got a 50 chance of ever becoming a
mother and that's maximum it's actually
lower than that in most countries I
could not find anywhere any example so
it's a toss of a coin turning 30 without
a child
seven years this month
so seven years ago I read a newspaper
article about falling birth rates uh
falling populations in Europe uh that
scared me
and to be honest with you I I read an
article that the UK or actually both
from my I've lost my accent you've kept
yours but I read that the UK is going to
become the most populous nation in
Europe
and to me I didn't believe this because
Germany has at least 15 20 million more
people right now you know how is Germany
going to lose so many people or has the
UK going to possibly add so many people
and I dismissed it
and two or three weeks later I thought
huh if Germany has had this really low
birth rate for like 40 50 years and
because people are living longer we
haven't really noticed the fall off yet
that could explain it I looked at data
and it was frightening because that's
exactly what was happening not just in
Germany but in Austria Switzerland Italy
Spain So Many Nations across Europe
and the biggest confusion to me was
why did I know this you know I I feel
I'm someone who is aware of world issues
I was aware of
um population decline in Japan
um I'm a little bit Spain and Italy 20
years ago when youth unemployment was
being blamed for low birth rates there
but when I saw how consistent it's been
for such a long period of time I wanted
to dive in and find a book I wanted to
find some explanation there's books
about it but they all focus on local
issues here's what's happening in Japan
here's the problem in Italy here's the
problem in Germany and that just did not
make sense to me for me there had to be
some kind of global Trend happening and
I needed to find out from my own sanity
as much as anything else why this was
going on
I get the sense that this is the most
dangerous of the existential risks and
the reason that I think population
collapse is the most dangerous is it
doesn't Galvanize anybody into action
there's no smoke in the sky there's no
incoming asteroids there's no movies
about Arnold Schwarzenegger coming down
naked from the the ceiling and crashing
through your house
this is the kind of existential risk
that creeps up on you year by year
Generation by generation nobody sees it
coming and when they do it is too late
and we still have people and news
articles and replies in comments where I
and Jordan Peterson worn the entire
world that this is something which is a
concern from people saying good there
are too many people on this planet in
any case
and you know you can understand
frankly a little bit naively if you
think there are too many people this can
sound like a good thing what I'd
encourage anybody who does with that
view is start to look at the
implications of this start to look at
what way this is going to impact all of
our Lives young and old and maybe it is
good for some people but we need to be
prepared for these changes and today
we're simply not I I agree with you
completely you know of all the threats
we face today this is the scariest and
it's exactly as you say this is a
background problem this is something we
read in the newspaper once or twice a
year it becomes a little these days it's
becoming more topical year by year which
is a good thing I think people are
starting to Galvanize but it's still a
background problem and to your point
absolutely this problem takes about 40
50 years to really take effect
and at that point if somehow magically
the birth rate went back to replacement
level so in Japan where I am right now
if that were to happen it would still
take 30 40 50 years for Japan to
re-stabilize itself
and that's because of the age balance
issue where you have so many old people
and you've lost the Young Generation who
are also the generation who would become
parents so even if they start having to
you still have this large
number of older people to take care of
that doesn't disappear for a long period
of time so I call it
um in my documentaries called birth Gap
um the Gap in the ages between the
number of old people supporting young
people and I call this birth Gap trap
once you're in it to get out of it you
actually need to go through more pain of
somehow encouraging people to consider
if they want to have more children while
still at the same time supporting old
people it's it's horrible oh so you're
going to end up with this sort of uh
hourglass shape to the demographic where
you're going to have a bottleneck of
competent adults you're going to have a
ton of young people and a ton of old
people and you're going to squeeze very
very hard on that group of adults in the
middle Okay so
whatever happened to the population bomb
because I remember that when I was
growing up that there was a a thing that
people were worried about the population
bomb was going to happen
yeah I mean it goes back to the book of
the of exactly that title written by
polar Ehrlich
um who still
um you know
expounding his views that uh children
are garbage I've heard him say that
um that women shouldn't be allowed to
have the number of children they want
um it's a horrible perspective on on
Humanity the irony is that book came out
uh late 1960s and
at that time we already knew that birth
rates were falling rapidly I think the
birth rate in the U.S for example
reached replacement level around that
time so the reality that there was ever
going to be a bomb uh really was
somewhat
a fantasy now are there challenges
environmentally from the increase in
population that we've seen in the time
yes it's certainly true since that time
of course the world's population has
increased but we saw the rate was
slowing rapidly everywhere and
population is a wonderful thing because
you can see relatively speaking so far
into the future other things we can't
possibly know what's the interest rate
going to be in 2050 we don't know well
the mortgage rates can be like what are
job opportunities we just simply don't
know those things but for example we
have a pretty good idea the number of 80
year olds there will be in the year 2100
because they were born in 2020 they
can't be any more than the people who
are already born and of course things
can happen the decades ahead but with a
pretty good idea about how people are
surviving so with the relative accuracy
we can actually project quite far into
the future in terms of populations and
the population bomb era people knew that
the world's population was going to Peak
around 10 billion give or take and
that's exactly what what's happening so
yeah the people today who think there's
too many people that's their view but
the reality is they should be
celebrating because we're already at the
peak effectively we're already just
coasting to the top of this roller
coaster and I really think people
um you know need to be looking at the
other side and most especially I'll just
finish on this point most especially we
need to be looking at this at an
individual country level we're not all
in the same roller coaster here or if we
are we're in different cars of a roller
coaster and Japan's up front with South
Korea and Italy and Germany the UK and
France and the US are kind of a little
bit farther back and nations in
sub-Saharan Africa are at the back of
this roller coaster but it's a CM roller
coaster that we're all on ultimately
just how bad is the birthright in
different countries
well yeah I mean it to me the scariest
um if I have to call it one country
would be South Korea where we're down to
around 0.8 and to put that in context
um
we're talking of a situation where the
number of children being born in South
Korea at the moment will fall by half
every 25 to 30 years
and that's a way to think of it the
birth rate numbers are not very helpful
um if we try and imagine the future
impact I mean what's the difference
between a fertility rate of 1.9 1.8 they
sound the same they're not
if we take a birth rate around 1.9 the
number of babies being born will fall by
half every 900 years or so it's all it's
effectively irrelevant you go to 1.8 and
that goes down to around 250 years and
every Notch you go down it gets deeper
and deeper and deeper in terms of how
far down this curve you are you've got
to look at other countries other regions
of course Taiwan is similar to South
Korea Hong Kong Singapore or very
similar as well Japan is a little higher
but because it's been going on so long
here in Japan the impact really is
starting to notice right now and finally
to answer your question China is
probably in terms of because of its size
the most scary in terms of what's about
to happen there in terms of that age
balance where I I just don't know how
China will cope with the number of old
people they have to support there Peter
Zion on this show said that he thinks
China's population will be down to 600
150 million by the year 2050. how
accurate do you think he is I think he's
pretty he's in the ballpark I think
absolutely what we're also unsure of is
high accurate the numbers out of China
are there's a lot of speculation
massaging of the figures I think yes and
I don't know if that's right or wrong
but
um I mean you just put yourself into a
society that has hadn't enforced I mean
one child policy not all families were
having one child it was more Regional uh
farmers were allowed to have to for
example and there were certain
um rules allowed people to have more so
the overall average was never one for
China but that was low and it's been at
a low point for a long time and just to
kind of emphasize what that means first
generation you have a little bit less
young people second generation because
there's less young people in the first
generation to have those children that's
when it really becomes noticeable and
third generation is when it gets
horrible because you really have so many
old people to take care of well
everybody remembers from the pandemic
the are not number right that when it's
above one for every infection there are
more infections when it's below one for
every infection there are fewer
infections and it's precisely the same
way that it works when it's children if
there are fewer children there are fewer
children to have fewer children and if
that Trend doesn't get reversed it is an
Ever more increasingly difficult Hill to
climb back up because you need mothers
to have 10 children each because there
are 10 times fewer children in there
okay so yeah a lot of the people that
are listening will be uh US Canada UK
Australia how are they looking in terms
of birth rate
um I mean all of those countries now are
at a point where it's deeply concerning
deeply concerning
um so we're talking numbers around 1.6
1.7 Canada I believe is 1.5
um so I think there was a time up until
seven eight nine years ago when we were
only looking at countries in in Europe
and Japan as the the countries that had
a problem
a contra argument for for the U.S which
has some validity is immigration is
higher there traditionally so the U.S
will be able to balance this a little
bit
um but still the trend has started and
it's really starting to to to to to to
gain traction
and let's not forget the U.S trades with
the rest of the world and if there's
less people in the rest of the world
particularly the industrialized world
that can buy products it's gonna affect
this will affect everybody irrespective
of what your local uh birth rate is is
anywhere suffering less badly
I bet your pardon I'm sorry where are
the places that have got the best
Birthright
you know you really have it's surprising
you might think
um that you wouldn't have to go too far
to find those but you really do you
almost have to literally go to
sub-Saharan Africa and start looking at
countries there and of course there's
countries like Nigeria with birther it's
still around five but there's other
countries in our sub-Saharan Africa like
Ethiopia like Malawi that they're down
to around four and they're falling quite
rapidly
um people might assume that countries
perhaps
um arabic speaking countries
um Muslim majority countries would be
countries that are higher uh in some
cases that's right but in other cases
it's not it's it's not something that
you know can easily be explained by by
religion or by culture
um the the biggest factor is poverty
taking people out of poverty means that
they're less likely to have very large
families 10 children four children six
children just happens less often
um but I I would like to kind of just
focus on one thing if I may about what
the actual reason for this is because
this is the journey I went on and you
know today we dwell on this overall
average number of children per woman
you might call it total fertility rate
um but it's an average and in my uh
career as a data analyst a data
scientist as we call it now you learn
very quickly the averages are nasty
things to be avoided at all costs
and what I try to do is find out well
below these averages you know what are
the underlying Trends and I don't
believe it had been done before I'm
writing a paper on it right now but it
turns out surprisingly well let me tell
you this in the 1980s mid 80s the
average mother in the US was having 2.5
children
recently
is 2.6 it's gone up
if you take
around 30 industrialized countries that
provide data to the UN to allow these
family size numbers to be calculated in
the mid 80s the overall average was 2.4
today it's 2.4 there is no difference
for the number of children that mothers
are having
and even to go further than that and
Japan which is wonderful there's so much
detailed data going back decades here
in 1973 which is an important year
because really the low birth rate crisis
started just right after 73. in 1973 six
percent of mothers were having four more
children
today that number is exactly the same
today six percent of mothers have four
more children in Japan
so what is it what is causing it we're
only left with one thing it's
childlessness
so to take Japan 1973 the average woman
um a bigger partner with a differently
six percent of women were childless
that rocketed in one year to 15 to 21
percent
and within three to four years was
around thirty percent there was a
phenomenal overnight change and the
exact same thing was happening in Italy
and Germany doesn't provide the full
data to go to this level of granularity
but on the surface level we can see the
same trend there was an overnight change
in
um
childlessness mothers weren't having
less children mothers today are not
having less children
so the issue really is not the birth
rate issue it's childlessness
and then you want to ask well okay why
are women more likely to be childish and
it's the same Trend by the way in the
U.S and the UK it's childlessness that's
driving this
um where numbers are
trending towards 30 35 in South Korea
and Italy it's it's 40 or more of of
women and therefore we suppose people
overall we measure women more than men
so that's why I quote you know numbers
for women you know why is this happening
maybe this is a good thing maybe women
don't want their children you know maybe
that's the answer maybe we have to
accept that and that's the society we're
now you know we've set ourselves up for
and we just accept the consequences well
it turns out from studies and from my
documentary talking to uh people in 24
countries
it's pretty clear that the vast majority
of people who do not have children
and I'm estimating 80 and it might be
higher
had plenty of children
they had assumed there'd be a moment in
time after education after careers when
it would be the right time but the right
time never came
and you know if you were to watch part
two of the documentary I almost suggest
you don't watch it alone because there's
some very emotional scenes with people
in their 40s men and women who get
deeply emotional about what went wrong
in life that they had planned their
children and why is this so important
well you know if we look at people who
have say two children they probably were
thinking of
two or three
people with three children they're
probably thinking of maybe two or three
or four people with five children they
were probably minded to have a large
family
so when we think of people with no
children it's easy to think that well
they were probably thinking of none or
one they wanted a small family or none
well no it's not true at all these
people were thinking of having two three
four five children just like the rest
what what didn't happen is they never
had the first child
and that's the key thing here after you
have your first child it's
you know they it's locked in the
percentage of people of one child who
will then go and have two to have three
to a four
um and those numbers are not changing at
all so what we have here is what I'm
calling an unplanned childlessness
crisis
you know it's it's a you know
and we don't make plans really as you
know we don't tell our kids at school or
college here is the kind of here's how
you're gonna have to navigate life
here's where the fertility window kind
of ends for one and here are the
challenges for men as well you know men
I think overestimate their ability when
they're older to find a young woman
who's able to have children
um the competition pool it gets very
intense when you're an older person you
know you may think you're technically
able to you probably are as a man but
you know you're competing with 30 year
old guys for the attention of the same
young woman
we're not telling young people about
what these challenges are to allow them
to plan their life better than than I
think many are are doing today
what are women's views on having
children when you speak to them
well
to be clear I'm
um myself
uh not supporting any form of
encouragement uh for women who don't
want children to have children that's
wrong and I will be the biggest
supporter of anyone who says children
are not for them neither of us are
advocating for the handmaid's tale here
yes exactly exactly
um now
um
my hypothesis from my interviews from my
research
um is that it's pretty much innate as to
whether you have the desired of children
or not now that desire can kick in quite
late you know we've interviewed people
who are 30 31 when suddenly the desire
came about
but that's quite rare most women I think
know quite early on in their 20s early
20s if they are minded to have a family
or not
and that can get a little bit fuzzy
because there's a lot of discussions
right now about the environment and
would you want to be you know bringing
your child into the world right now but
I think innately and that is supported
by by studies there's a Gallup study
that's run every 10 or 15 years in the
U.S and they've been finding around 95
of people have this desire for children
so when you ask well what do women want
I think we've got to treat women based
on whether they're the would be in the
group who don't want children who plan
to be childless or those who don't and
I'm not here to kind of um persuade
either group but I've I'm here to say do
you know what
um they're an insane number of people
out there who are living lives without
families who had actually wanted that to
happen and who are scratching their
heads frankly wondering why did that not
happen one of the problems that you come
up against here is the inner Citadel
that people retreat into right the
number of people that I see online uh
both men and women who have struggled to
find a partner who have left it too late
and then who Retreat from I wanted to
have children left it too late and
couldn't because I leaned into my party
boy or Boss [__] lifestyle
from that to I never wanted to have kids
in any case bringing children into this
world is bad for the environment it's
generally immoral because of how
disgusting this place is it's stopping
me from going on holiday as much as I
want I care about my job I care about my
friends I care about my partnering I
care about my
that's the inner Citadel they Retreat to
and it makes it very difficult it must
make it very difficult as a researcher
to get um genuine responses from people
now credit to you that in your
documentary you've got a lot of people
to open up who have either struggled or
passed the fertility window or are
struggling right now to have children to
say
I really wanted to have kids I'm 43
and it's not happening and with the man
that I love or the woman that I love
and when up we're not going to be able
to have children and that is an
incredibly Brave uh position to take
because it's significantly easier to say
to come up with some excuse about how
it's not your fault about how it wasn't
because you decided to wait and
sometimes people don't meet their
partner until later in life sometimes
people aren't financially set up until
later in life Etc et cetera Etc
but for people to actually
own that choice that they made to not
have children
is a brave position and I wonder how
much of the data gets skewed by people
that Retreat into that inner Citadel as
a cope to uh justify why they didn't
manage to make it work
yeah
um it's a great Point
actually uh ended up traveling to 24
countries to to make the documentary and
um you know part of the reason for that
was to try and meet as many people from
as many cultures and many ages and
different circumstances as possible and
you're absolutely right you know there
aren't many people you would meet you
usually meet them in their homes and
chit chat for a little bit and then we'd
do like a one-hour interview and it was
usually towards the end of the interview
when they were comfortable they would
start to curve
tell you their true feelings on this
issue I think another example is someone
who saw an early screening a woman a
lady who saw
um you know who doesn't have a child she
saw an early version of the documentary
and she was in initially quite almost
offended
by you know why are you talking about
the subject matter and she called me
afterwards and we had lunch and she told
me that the weekend after
she didn't open her curtains she spent
the entire weekend in her apartment
Coming to Terms remembering that she had
wanted a child
and then come on Monday morning she was
done she'd gone through that grief
process and had been Insider for you
know
more than a decade
um had accepted it and was moving on
that's not a unique story
um and and just to to explain it wasn't
just uh data and and interviews there
are many support groups online for
people who are
childless not by choice
um who for for men and women and the
their vast support organizations out
there and if there is anyone listening
I'd encourage you to reach out to those
what's your what's your recommendation
for those
um there's a A lady called Jody day who
runs a support group called Gateway
woman
um and Jody is an access point both to
men's groups and to women's groups
there's also an organization called
World childless week
um who uh are
a support group for people who plan to
have children
um those groups are incredibly helpful
I've spent a lot of time interviewing
them getting to know them the one term
they use
is grief
and
it sounds a big word but when you speak
to people who had wanted their children
who wanted a legacy who'd wanted the
future and all the things they cannot do
um
it's really uh it really is grief
and I think as a broader Society I think
we need to understand for example a
small Point
um was it's a big point to to people in
this situation
people in work environments talking
about their kids
you know you'll have co-workers talking
about what they did the weekend with
their kids for some people who have not
been able to have children that is a
very difficult thing to hear and you
hear stories of people having to go to
the bathroom go out of the office just
stay away while that conversation is
being had I don't think we shouldn't you
know I just think we just we need to be
more sensitive that there are I believe
up to 30 percent of adults who now are
effectively living lives without
children who you know would have planned
to have them just to hammer that point
home that you made earlier on is it your
view that ish about 80 percent of women
are childless due to life circumstances
that's exactly what my point in it there
was a study done by Professor rinska
Kaiser which was a meta study and that's
the exact number he came up with
um and he's kind of supported by other
evidence out there so uh Professor
Kaiser identified 10 of women who
medically could never have had children
there was something fundamentally sadly
that meant that they couldn't another 10
were women who had chosen not their
children and as Julie day says there's a
whopping 80 percent like her who always
plant of children and through pure
circumstances
the biggest circumstance being not
having the right partner at the right
time
in the right time meaning when you're
you know in your fertility window
so uh yes 80 when you say not having the
right partner at the right time you do
mean not having the right partner early
enough right or perhaps I suppose you
could potentially have the the right
partner too early then sticking about
for too long and then you fall out of
love there is some evidence that I'm
sure that you've seen from The
evolutionary psychology literature if
you and a partner stay together for
sometimes over five years but between
five and eight really seems to be a
sweet spot and a child hasn't come into
this world people can find themselves
falling out of love with their partner
for kind of no real reason and they
don't really know where it comes from
you know the cute way that she used to
sip her coffee on the morning actually
drives you up the wall or the fact that
he always leaves the forks out on the
the dining room table which he used to
think was a little bit okay now it's
turning you inside out what it seems
like is that there is an evolutionary uh
program that runs that says if you're in
a relationship a committed relationship
with a partner that you're invested in
children should arrive at some point if
children don't arrive because in
ancestrally no one would have been
electing not to have children there were
no reliable forms of birth control there
is an incompatibility somewhere between
us two it might be me it might be you
but what I do know is that if we both
split up I have a better chance there's
a 50 chance that it could be you or me
and if we decide to split up so people
that have been in relationships that
have said I found the love of my life at
21 years old but we're gonna Hang Fire
until we're 29 and then we'll decide to
do it and they get to 27 and they find
ah I thought that this was the one and
it's actually not that is a
psychological bias which everybody needs
to learn about and that's actually the
one I would say the overwhelming
majority would be people not finding the
right partner early enough however there
is the potential that people could find
the right partner almost too early you
find it at 18 19 20 you stick about for
a long time and then this bias kicks in
so just to drill that home 80 percent of
women and this is meta studies
replicated pretty robust as far as it
goes
yes are childless due to life
circumstances and the most common life
circumstance is that they didn't have
the right partner what about having the
right partner and uh waiting so one one
side of this would be singleton-ness I
suppose would be contributed to by being
single
another element would be having a
partner and then deciding to wait did
you look at how that gets split up
within that 80 percent
um well for sure I mean I I I I
there's a quote in my mind that might be
from Julie day again that there's like
50 different ways to be childless
there's so many possibilities of what
can happen in the circumstances of life
um but what I my interpretation of it is
this today uh you may know that the
majority of college students in the US
and actually most other countries are
women so today undergraduate students in
the US there's nine and a half million
female women and 6.5 million men
and it's 30 less
and there was a study done on on Tinder
uh by uh again I think it was a Dutch
University against University I believe
that showed that women on Tinder uh
effectively swipe right 91 more of the
time if someone has a master's degree as
a Man compared to you know yeah
bachelor's degree so women want to match
with someone at least as educated as
they are but yet the number of men
through the education system so this is
one of the challenges women are looking
competing with each other for a pool of
men that aren't really there anymore but
as well as that I think as a woman and
I'm conscious that I I you know I'm a
man and you know I have a daughter a
mother sisters uncle's aunts but I'm
still this is my perspective of what I'm
looking at from a man so apologies if
that offends anybody but
my belief is that women going through
education you studied year 22 23 uh you
might have some college debt you want to
get started on the career path you want
to work for three four five years to get
established because you know when you
have your first child things are going
to change and you've just studied for
four years at college and you've got
college debt so why are you even going
to think about having a child or even
being in a relationship necessarily that
would be with the right partner to be a
father of a child until you're getting
close to around 30 when things change
seem to change
and you know one of the facts that that
came up across every country we looked
at was that women turning 30 without a
child if you're childless at 30 the at
most you've got a 50 chance of ever
becoming a mother and that's maximum
it's actually lower than that in most
countries I could not find anywhere any
example so it's a toss of a coin turning
30 without it without it without a child
now now we're in this situation maybe
where you're into your early 30s and
you're hearing about egg freezing you're
hearing about
technologies that might make you think
it's okay to delay things well I I
interviewed five fertility doctors
including Kim Kardashian's uh fertility
doctor in La uh fertility doctor in
Tokyo
um and they're all saying the same thing
that we overestimate these Technologies
we not only overestimate the chance egg
freezing and IVF will work we don't take
into account that as women's bodies get
older the chance of not going full term
gets higher and higher
so
we get to the point I think early 30s as
a woman we're now thinking well I should
look for the right partner
but you might not meet that right person
it might take two years three years to
meet that right person now you're 35.
and you know what you might find age 35
he wasn't the person for you and now
you're 38.
and this is a life story of so many
people I met so many women in their 30s
it's like where did life go I had to
kind of follow this path I had to pursue
my dream my education my career and I'm
not one to for a second say that's wrong
but I think we have to make people aware
of the younger age that the challenges
are probably going to be greater to
maintain fertility to a point in the
moment where you kind of are ready and
at the same time to have a partner it's
it's it's it's much more difficult than
I think people estimate let's not forget
ancestrally that
most girls that made it to the age of 14
were pregnant by 15. and then by the
time that they were 28 they were a
grandmother because they're 14 or 15
year old had had a child and
the I think quite rightly because we
need laws to protect children who can't
consent to anything or really understand
or bring up a child in an effective way
what we have done
is detach
a sense of whatever is normal for having
children you know to have if you hear
that a girl has a child at the age of 18
you think wow
that's young you go that's past Peak
fertility that's after Peak fertility
so when you're talking oh let's double
that age and start looking for a partner
it is no surprise that it's a challenge
and I mean you are you are uh singing
The Mating crisis back to me here right
which is my current pet Obsession and uh
I spoke to you before we got started
that your work and how it relates in
with what I'm currently working on uh it
is the downstream effect of this and it
is there's three layers that I see to
The Mating crisis so individual
happiness societal stability and then
civilizational collapse right uh
civilizational collapse you've got
sorted like we can take that black pill
as far as we want like that's you've
written the book that would have been
the appendix to whatever it is that I
end up coming up with and I'm very very
glad that it's been done
there is no layer of the current mating
world that I think is making people
happy
I don't think that it is effective on an
individual level I don't think it's
effective on a societal level in terms
of stability and I don't think it's
effective in terms of global population
moving on from that very positive Point
what about men we've spoken about women
and their approaches to uh their views
of children it seems like most women on
average wanted to have a family struggle
to find a partner and then didn't
women fundamentally are The Gatekeepers
to relationships and and sex overall the
men are the protagonists and women men
of the supply and women of the demand
you could say in one way or another uh
did you look at men and their attitudes
to having children
um yes absolutely and
um
I find it more difficult to interview
men and for men to open up talking about
this
um but I was very grateful to finding
um groups online support groups for men
um who allowed me to interview them to
kind of discover their support groups
and to
understand their feelings I don't think
there's any fundamental difference
between
the proportion of men and the proportion
of women who have a desire to have
children nor indeed the grief impact of
not having a child as a man there's
almost this feeling that you are not a
man I want to say that you know as as
it's it's it's
I'm repeating what I've sensed and what
I've written in in research as one of
the reasons I think men find it really
hard the idea that you know in future
they will not have something to pass on
the Legacy to give the children that
they thought they would have
and I I don't differentiate what is
different about Mana I think we falsely
assume that because biologically
technically biologically we're able to
have children
late into life that that means we don't
have to worry at that younger age of the
30s but it's back to the point that
we're all competing you know the the
most eligible men are competing amongst
each other for the most eligible females
in whatever way I know it's your topic
at whatever way that works out but by
definition every year you get older as a
man you're less eligible you might not
like it and unless you're um you know
super wealthy person on Hollywood ever
you know we see those extreme examples
they are there but there are the
exceptions just because of Leonardo
DiCaprio can continue to cycle his
girlfriends out at the age of 25 doesn't
necessarily mean that you can
exactly right and yet man I think aren't
fully aware of that so I have seen uh it
is a midlife crisis a man in their early
40s who suddenly discovered that dating
isn't quite as easy as it was five years
earlier
or that they're not dating the woman
that they would have wanted to date are
starting to confront this potential
reality that they may have left it too
late too so the Dynamics are a little
bit different but the end result is the
same
um
there's one point I think I nearly said
it two or three times before but it's a
great analogy and it's it's it's not
mine I was interviewing
um Megan McArdle a Washington Post
columnist who who writes about this
topic from time to time and she'd give a
great analogy of grandmother's lamp I
don't know if you've come across this
analogy but the the analogy is as a
young girl unless he goes to her
grandmother's house every weekend
and every weekend the grandmother they
get their coats and they go out and they
go through every antique lamp store
every lamp store trying to find a lamp
and the grand daughter says Grandma why
do we always go out finding a lamp the
rest of your house is perfect everything
couldn't be nicer and grandmother says
that's why I can't find a lamb it has to
match with everything else in the house
and the analogy being to dating that I
think as we delay things into our 30s
and 40s to find that magic person
um it gets harder because we we've
already built Our Lives we already know
where we want to live we've got our kind
of career we've got our friends circles
we know whether we'd like to you know
ski or go to you know the mountains in
the summer or to the beach so we're
trying to find someone who is that much
doing that in your 20s is a lot easier
earlier because you're helping to build
and shape your lives together so to your
point earlier I I do think if there's an
answer to this I do some optimism that
young people will solve this
um I mean I've seen conversations open
amongst College age children High School
age children
um
between themselves and I think the
answer will be to find a way for people
to have children younger again the way
that happened in the past but at the
same time in 10 career opportunities and
that's going to need some form of
re-engineering of societies we know it
it's not an easy thing but this this
challenge you know we're gonna have to
find some way to solve it because
otherwise it's going to be uh very
painful for a lot of people around the
world let me give you an exclusive
insight into some of the research that
I've been doing for my stuff but you may
think that women who earn a lot more may
readily accept their role as Breadwinner
and settle into a relationship with a
man who earns less however research
suggests that the more professionally
successful a woman is the stronger her
preference for successful men in a study
of financially successful newlywed women
research has concluded that quote
successful women place an even greater
value than less successful women on
mates who have professional degrees High
School State high social status and
greater intelligence this trend is also
present in cross-cultural contexts
separate studies of 1670 Spanish 288
Jordanian 127 Serbian and 1851 English
women all found that high resource women
desired mates with greater status and
more resources in general single women
are three times as likely as men to say
that they wouldn't consider a
relationship with someone making less
than them and this trend is worsened the
the more professionally successful a
woman is
and it doesn't surprise me at all I I
it's what I see that women and I think
it's a natural thing do want to to marry
someone at least a successful as they
are and by definition as women are
getting more and more educated more
successful which is great in itself of
course it is the pool of eligible man
gets gets smaller it's what I call the
tall girl problem
so if you are a girl who is six foot one
without heels you're stuck trying to
date professional athletes as you rise
up through your own competence and
dominance hierarchy there is an Ever
decreasing pool of men that you can be
fundamentally attracted to
um so I mean why and someone made a
really great comment um on a post that I
put up about this recently
and they said I have two daughters and
I'm concerned about this problem but
also I want my daughters to get the
absolute best that they can both of them
are incredibly competent and I replied
and I said
if and when I hopefully do have a
daughter uh I absolutely do want the
same I would want the absolute best for
her too why should it be the case that a
woman that commits herself to
conscientious industrious hard work in
both education and employment and
manages to achieve everything that she's
wanted professionally should settle
settle for something that she doesn't
feel is worthy of her in the mating
Market
well there's no reason for it but there
is this that is the individual level
when you start to smear this out across
a population level or a societal level
there's just not enough men in the pool
for all of these high performing women
and I because of the mating preferences
that are predisposed into both men and
women
there's some challenges here so
rolling the clock forward we've looked
at the individual motivations which I
really really wanted to get out of you
one of the other most common uh reasons
or justifications that I hear from
people is cost of living is too high I
can't bring a child into this world in
any case what role does that play
well this is an interesting one and
you're right it's uh the first comment
uh that many many people make and a
sense it's true for these people and for
their peer groups for society life is
expensive today but for me you've got to
stand back and say well wait a minute
first of all if we go back 30 40 50 60
years ago post-war time people were much
much poorer than they are today and
we're still having families actually
quite large families is that adjusted
for inflation and cost of living
yes well I I mean the point it's a
general Point uh the general point is
that if you look at poorer times
whether it's in the industrialized world
or elsewhere in the past people were
having uh
larger families and we're poor adjusted
for inflation so it can't just be about
money so you then say well what might it
be and I think it comes down to
prioritization because I think today
people's priorities are first and
foremost well rent or buy a nice
apartment as much as you can maybe a car
possibly two cars a vacation well why
not two vacations
um maybe during the the golf club the
tennis club all the things that kind of
society has programmed us to Aspire to
and we aspire to it because our friends
are doing it it it becomes the norm so
when you've done that and you've got
those things
what capacity is there left financially
time wise to have a family so I think
it's it's the affordability question
really is one about prioritization and
I'm not saying that people should
re-prioritize unless they want to but
again I think it's a message I'd like
younger people to be hearing as they're
under 25s you're still building their
career in particular
who you know I I would like to kind of
forewarn that you know it it may well be
that all of your priorities leave you in
this situation where the idea of having
a family is too expensive and that might
be a fundamental reason not to so
Finance I think is understandable but
because of the past when people were
poor having large families and because
of all the other things these people
have all the Commodities uh that that
they somehow do manage to I I think it's
um it's not moot point but it's not as
simple as saying oh money is a a problem
what about environmentalism
and of course we get this a lot and you
know I I do have concerns about the
environment I
uh my own view is that uh putting less
pressure on the environment is a good
thing I think the future should be one
that we aspire to put a little pressure
on the planet as as possible I'm not all
doom and gloom because I think we will
cope with things we'll work our way
through it
but in terms of
population
childbirth and the environment you know
I I don't know if this is a good analogy
or not but I'm going to share it with
you for the first time you know I
imagine that you know some world leader
commission three
experts to come up with a solution to
the environmental problem what's the
most practical
and the first expert comes along with
this crazy idea the crazy idea is we're
going to make the planet bigger yeah we
need more space we're going to figure
out a way to kind of make it bigger
and the kind of leader just rolls his
eyes and said well that's not practical
and the next person says you know what
we're going to tell people to have less
children
and you look at the data and that
doesn't work either I mean the reality
is populations have their own tractions
so I put those two groups together and
the third person which is where my mind
is says do you know what it's
impractical to make the planet bigger
it's really impractical to tell people
to have less children it doesn't work
and even if it did it takes about 30
years for people to come become
consumers first it's a really
inefficient way of trying to Tinker with
you know environmental issues the Third
Way is to say you know what the planet's
the size is the population is going to
be 10 billion like it or not it is
that's locked in let's deal with those
things and let's look at consumption
let's look at manufacturing let's look
at Technologies that can reduce our
footprint in any sense so anybody who
thinks that you lowering the birth rate
is a magic can I give you an another
number here
so I've seen more than one study that's
estimating that the footprint
of under 30 year olds in industrialized
countries is around eight percent you
know consumption really Rockets between
30 and 65 and then it goes down very
quickly again
if we were to have half the number of
children currently currently in the
industrialized World from tomorrow it's
down by half
thank you
after 30 years
that would reduce total consumption by
four percent only four percent and that
would take 30 years to get to that point
you know after 20 years you're only down
two percent we don't have
30 40 years to solve environmental
issues or that's what I'm hearing at
least from from those concerned
trying to enforce people to have less
children is a really inefficient way to
try and solve any environmental issues
let's not forget that it's not people
trying to enforce anything it's cultural
pressure it's cultural bullying it's a
swath of articles that talk I mean there
was a an anti-natalist
uh parade like March thing here in
Austin Texas toward the back end of last
year
everybody dressed in all black like the
the least fun least cool parade that you
could think of you think parade and you
think ticker tape and and good music
none of that and um it is something
given the challenges that we're facing
in The Mating Market with regards to uh
industrialization and its uh problems
associated with birth rates with regards
to women leaving it too late trying to
find a partner all of that stuff
someone coming in and kicking the horse
when it's on the floor and saying ah and
you shouldn't be doing it in any case
to me is just pouring kerosene on what
is already a pretty big Blaze and I I
is the thing that I'm railing against
the most at the moment when I see it
online because it's just such a stupid
absolutely stupid point of view to say
you are fundamentally wrong and broken
and bringing a child into this world
because of the cost of living they're
going to have an awful life well it's
the best time to live on Earth ever in
history
right the fact that you're having an
existential crisis because you don't get
the same car that your friends on
Instagram do is no bearing on the
quality of life right yeah yeah and when
you roll it into environmentalism when
you roll it into the cultural pressures
when you roll it into the cost of living
and all of that sort of stuff
culturally reinforcing a
um
trend of childlessness somehow being
associated with freedom when 80 of women
planned on having kids and couldn't
you are encouraging a world
in which eighty percent of childless
women
are suffering and you're contributing to
it yeah and we haven't even talked about
the long-term consequences here um you
know but this this is a problem that
ultimately leads to a lot of people
later in life living a life alone and
then dying alone there's a loneliness
crisis happening right here in Japan
right now it's a humanitarian crisis and
you would think okay well that's Japan
it's you know it's so far you know down
the track with this but no it's not just
Japan if you go to Brazil you have the
same thing happening in Brazil birth
rates are falling so fast in Brazil you
wouldn't think it and you have these
elderly parents either they may have had
one child the child may have emigrated
so this humanitarian crisis of lonely
old people whether they've had children
or not but particularly if they've never
had children is something that we need
to confront because otherwise people are
just going to be left to
you know die away in their homes
um
so I I really worry that people aren't
thinking about those consequences and if
I can say again we try and you know
explain in the documentary what life is
like for older people in this position
and again
um
let me just put it this way
when you hear
people in their 80s with no family
contemplating
ending their life
you know it's bad
or if you talk to a crematorium director
in Germany
who refused in the end to do the
interview because his superiors wouldn't
let him
talking about the number of services
well there are no Services people with
no friends and family being buried
and then you hear their concerns a
little bit off camera
the treatment these people had had
because they can see that the bruises on
bodies they can see
um
well things that tell doctors
um or people kind of
you know looking at what happened end of
life for these people determining that
those last years
were not pleasant at all when you're
talking about bruises on bodies are you
referring to abuse by carers or are you
referring to Falls and and bumps on
their own
um I'm talking I have been told directly
about abuse from carers
um and this was partly on camera a lot
off camera a lot of messages there's a
documentary I'd love to make as a
follow-up this was Germany but I believe
it's only happening there where it was
obvious from strut marks on the corpses
from the skin color
um from malnutrition that these people
were not being looked after but without
any family to come and make sure that
things are okay
um
it it
um yeah it's a harrowing side to to life
so I think this documentary took me into
two places I never expected to go
um at heart I'm a data analyst I just
wanted to understand the trend but this
chalices trend and the kind of
loneliness and grief from that and then
the loneliness later in life from these
old people were just two Horrors that
you know I I I I for whatever reason I
feel
I through the documentary helped uncover
and I I think with what's happening to
the world these crises people need to
know about it that that's people need to
understand
that you know and we're not going to
transform the world into older people
today who didn't have children are not
going to have children I think it's
societies we need to be better looking
after those people so there's lots of
things we need to be thinking about here
obviously one of the implications as
well of an aging Society is that if
there are more old people than young
people there are fewer young people to
look after the old people I once got
told this by Carl Benjamin he's a
YouTuber called Sargon of a cad and he's
quite a hardcore conservative and he is
very unpopular in certain circles but
he's a good friend
and he said it was about a year ago and
he said to me
um
in his sort of typically bombastic way
he felt it was a moral imperative for
people to have children if they could
and I was like ah whoa whoa they get
perilously close to the handmaid's tale
stuff but then he started digging into
it a little bit more and I think that
there is a kernel of Truth in this sort
of shiny uh delivery
what he said was what you're doing if
you do grow older without contributing
to the pool of young people is you are
taking out of that
with regards to GDP Innovation care like
literally the care of that let's say
that you have a child and there is a one
in one thousandth chance that they
become an elderly care person right and
there is a one in one thousandth chance
that they become a nurse and what all
the way up right you're contributing to
this pool even if it's just people that
drive uh GDP so that the lights stay on
and so that the government can pay for
subsidies for the carers for the old
people you're extracting from that pool
whilst having contributed nothing to it
now sure you've contributed GDP but that
we don't need more money we need is more
people and
that's really stuck with me
um thinking about that thinking about
the
uh this sort of contributory hypothesis
around what happens when you bend the
shape of a population's demographics
yeah and I wouldn't go uh to that point
I think it's ultimately up to Choice
it's a choice whether to have children
or not it's a choice how many children
you have I would agree The Good the good
news for me is we don't really need to
worry about that given that these 80
percent of childless people had wanted
to have children if we can fix that's
not the right word if we can in some way
help address the societal issues that
have led to a situation where such a
large number of people are childless who
want to have children bearing in mind
that many of those will have two three
four plus children it will actually read
I mean the math is actually very nice it
will rebalance everything back to
replacement level that's where the focus
needs to be in my opinion that is a
really good point that I totally hadn't
thought about that we're facing down
this
um Bleak future of an Ever decreasing
number of people having a ever
decreasing number of people
but on average 80 of people that didn't
have children wanted to it's not like
there is this if it was eighty percent
of people didn't have children and
didn't want to we got we're looking at
enforced child birth or like artificial
wombs or sperm donors and uh some Matrix
style Farm of childbots
it's not
most women that didn't have kids wanted
to have kids they couldn't due to life
circumstances they were um how would you
say uh physiologically capable of doing
it it just didn't get they didn't get it
right so the fix
is of all of the different nightmares
that we could exist in ours is the most
luxurious
that's right and you know when I started
the project you know I I was quite
um accepting that I would find it a
different conclusion the conclusion May
well have been you know what people just
don't want to have kids anymore uh
didn't seem to make great sense to me
because why would we change so suddenly
uh given our species as being around for
millennium you know our ancestors before
that but if that had been the outcome I
would have been someone to say you know
what here's my researchers my
documentary but we've got to accept this
um you know we're going to not fizzle
out but there's going to be a
civilization change
um but the reality is actually and it
made so much more sense that there is no
real change in desire it's the society
has changed and I don't want to make it
sound easy that um we can just you know
flick the switch and say you know what
this is great people just need to have
the kids sooner or they need to kind of
think about this more there needs to be
societal changes somewhere and I
actually you know education is something
where you know are we really using our
time well to go to college you know to
21 22-23 and then maybe get a master's
degree or do some extra studies to spend
their 20s studying when I look back and
I I do have three kids of my own who are
kind of just college or post College age
now and you actually Wonder
how much of what they learned was really
relevant and I know you can't identify
what might be relevant given you want to
equip people with as broad skills as
possible
but I think we could be taking one two
years out of the education cycle without
much difficulty having people on a
career path earlier and then allowing
people to top up education later in life
when they know exactly what education is
relevant to the career path they want
did you read Richard Reeves of boys and
men which came out last year
I've heard of it but I have not read it
short book easy read highly recommended
very pertinent to what you do one of the
things that he puts forward in that book
is red shirting for boys which is
holding boys back by one year
one of the things that I didn't bring up
to him and one of the things that he
doesn't talk about is you push back by
one more year the
it's not a fertility window quite so
much for men it's an attraction window
right uh you push that back by one more
year and that is
something that I absolutely have not
thought about and it I'm trying not to
lose my [__] thinking about it that's
crazy okay I
one uncompleted Loop before we get under
the global stuff one uncompleted Loop
with regards to the trends of how it's
um how it affects people personally why
is it the increasing industrialization
across the board is associated with a
decrease in birth rate because as far as
I can see and I may have got this wrong
the only thing that ties all of these
different countries together you make a
great job of it in the documentary where
you explained that in Japan uh schooling
is uh private and you pay for it
somewhere else it's socialized in
displaced cost of living is high in this
place cost of living is low in this
place there's tons of support for
mothers that want to get maternity leave
and this place is basically not at all
this is super egalitarian this is
the cultural milieu of all of these
different places could not be more
different yeah
what is the what are the trends uh that
draw all of those different countries
together given their differences and why
is it that industrialization is
associated with declining birth rate in
your view
well industrialization I think has been
driven
um
by women coming into the workforce and
women gaining educations equal or not
exceeding men
and that's a good thing I'm not I'm I
support that I want to make that really
really clear but the reality is the
fertility window is being kind of
narrowed and narrowed and narrowed so
that in the past you would have to do
and industrialized nations but this is
now this is now rolling out across the
world you've got countries like
Bangladesh with a birth rate of 2.0 just
below replacement level India has just
gone below replacement level you know
Nepal is at the same point Thailand is
1.5 it's it's the same as much of much
of Europe
um and again if you look at education
systems in in Thailand they're
fascinating it's the same thing out of
every 10 college students in Thailand I
think it's seven or female it's six and
a half or seven are female and three and
a half men and what's happened there
is a situation where young men feel that
they can't compete you know there's two
sides of this coin the woman can't find
the educated man to can they want to
date you then have the men who are kind
of shunned because they're they're not
smart enough they're not educated enough
they're you know not not the person so
you have this crisis of young men in
Thailand who are
either not going to college or dropping
out of college becoming taxi drivers
drinking alcohol doing drugs and
creating a whole world of alternate
problems which make the whole situation
more more difficult again so I don't
there's an imbalance right now in
society between women's education and
the time to have a family
we think we've been smart uh through
fertility treatments enabling people as
much as they want now to have children
in their 30s as they would have done in
their 20s it's it it's not even remotely
close
to being similar
um and back to your question
industrialization or the process moving
towards industrialization has you know
in the developing world to call it that
as well as the industrialized World
um create this situation where women are
more incentivized to have families into
their 30s when our bodies are not geared
up for it and are not likely to ever be
I'm not hearing any
Confidence from fertility doctors that
um you know the technologies that
they're creating and certainly these
things like you know external worms I
mean that's just science fiction right
now you know egg freezing is actually I
thought it was a wonderful idea when I
first heard about it well this is great
you know I thought you know I'll tell
everybody you know
um you know someone once said maybe it's
a good college gift a graduation gift
for for you know for our daughters to
kind of get their eggs frozen and maybe
it is but I'm saying now there's an
altered side to this because if you
think well this is okay you know with
frozen eggs you know we can you know
women can now work longer into their 30s
and 37 38 it'll be fine but actually
again it's back to well have you got the
right partner at the right time you know
or maybe you're just one uh road before
that promotion that you've always wanted
or maybe it's just you're tired now
people get tired as they get older and
the idea of wait 20 years of raising a
kid until I'm in my 60s is that what I
really want to do so I don't think you
know I I think
education is such a positive thing I
don't want for a second anyone to
misinterpret me I think we need to
re-engineer the education system and
break it up a little bit more so that
people can start their Cur people can
start their careers earlier
and consider having a family earlier and
then continue education and continue
their career at that point this is the
challenge of talking about this topic
generally especially because it seems
like
um increasing female achievement in
education and employment is one of the
primary driving forces that's
contributing to both The Mating crisis
and this birth Gap problem
a very easy rebuttal is
are you saying that we should roll back
parity in education which women only
just achieved Title IX was only brought
in 50 years ago and you're telling us
that just after we've managed to gain
footing that we've been fighting for for
so long
that you want us to stop going to school
that you want women to not be able to go
into the workplace that women should be
held back that they should be domestic
prostitutes as one particularly irate
commenter accuse me of of proposing
uh no is the answer I mean clearly
um that that would be fundamentally
wrong will there be a a risk and
tendency of some Nations perhaps uh more
totalitarian Nations to push those
policies I really do worry that we're
going to see things like that happen
um and that's a terrible thing
um I I think we need to re-engineer the
education system for everybody frankly
um the idea for example we you know we
graduate college and we're kind of on
the you know that that you know first
rung of the ladder looking for our first
position and that's going to Define our
career
um and then we want to get to a certain
point why why can't people start their
career age 30. why don't we have mass
recruitment rise of first-time intakes
of people who have had their family
first and for that to be a normal thing
I know that can happen in some instances
but it's not societally normal
and you know people have said to me well
if you start your career in your 30s
you're not going to be earning very much
money so is it really worth it but you
know what we're gonna have to push a
retirement age way up the idea we're
retiring you know 65.70 the reality is
for young people today retirement of it
you've got to be looking at age 75 maybe
even 80. so starting a career at age 30
or even 35 is fine you've still got
decades to kind of build up the the
wealth I guess the but you've got this
results in your career window as your
grandfather probably did in his
or maybe even longer correct correct
okay what does this mean for economics
if we do have this declining birth rate
you've mentioned already that
um America is this sort of fundamental
supplier across the world and if the
Market's reduce and all the rest of it
we've already got some turmoil with
regards to interest rates all the rest
of it what does a declining birth rate
mean in terms of both
Countrywide and uh Global GDP
yeah it's it's not good in fact there's
nothing good about it
um I mean the reality you know I think
people imagine and it's understandable
that you think we can kind of
slowly slide our populations down slide
our economies down so we all just shrink
a little bit you know year by year that
it's almost going to be like you know an
airplane kind of slowly coming into land
and we'll have this kind of resettling
it's not like that people say
um there was only two billion people on
the planet 100 years ago why is it a
problem that we would go back to that
so when you the transition is the
problem the transition is a bumpy ride
that the transition is really a nosedive
and one other factor is that we have no
example of a country that went through
this and came out the other side there
are no examples of countries in history
unless it was a period of famine or War
that went down with such a low birth
rate as we were saying now and then
rebalanced itself so there's no examples
to follow here no it's like civilization
in history has ever recovered from this
type of population collapse that's what
you're saying that's exactly what I'm
saying I should clarify noon known
civilization and history for where we
have data
um it has gone through this and you know
that's directly from the words you know
from the research and from demographers
so to come back to economics though
let's just look at
certain things if you can imagine
the housing market I used to to live or
my company today is based in Detroit
Michigan Detroit Michigan I love
michiganders I love this city it's
really reinvented itself but it went
through a phase when it was uh I built
the fourth or fifth largest city in the
U.S population of around 2 million uh
around 50 years ago and then quite
quickly that population dropped down to
today it's around six or seven hundred
thousand so it's Fallen by over 60 65
percent well during that transition
which is what we all can expect to go
through
what happened
streets became not empty overnight but
one house became vacant
and then another house and then another
house
and then Vermin came into these streets
and then the taxes collected by the city
to pay for the street lights wasn't
enough or to maintain the roads in order
to collect the garbage
and you had this street after Street
after Street of dereliction but with
people families living in amongst this
dereliction she just can't scale down
towns or cities it becomes a patchwork
now
Detroit's falling population was not to
do with fertility rates is to do with
the other industry you know moving out
of the city it was to do with certain
Dynamics in Detroit but it's a really
good example of what it's going to be
like you cannot skill cities then you
take something
um like our national debts
and our national debts we're assuming
you know that I think in future that
future workers well we are assuming
future workers are going to pay the
interest rates to maintain that debt
but if you have a shrinking Workforce
to pay off the national debt
it the by definition the interest rate
payments are going to get higher and
higher and higher so you're going to
have these workers
paying more and more tax not just to
cover the cost of the old people that
they're going to have to you know in
terms of welfare in terms of pension
systems but also to try and you know
maintain their cities and also to pay
off the national debt and it doesn't
stop there every which way you look at
this economically I mean think of it as
a long-term recession a recession that
will be measured in decades I mean
that's that's what we've got to brace
ourselves for and if I could turn it
around to one final example imagine
you're a coffee shop owner in a little
town there's 10 coffee shops
every year your Cafe like all the others
have got less customers
less and less and less and you're
looking at your staff and okay this
population's shrinking but you're trying
to balance it are you going to invest
you know repainting the cafe to try and
encourage customers well some might but
I think a lot of those cafes are going
to start really suffering you know
you're going to notice that almost no
one's going there you know in the
mornings it might be just a few people
at lunch time and just I think living in
an environment where there isn't the
kind of enthusiasm the reason the kind
of growth and positivity economically
about you know let's kind of expand our
businesses hire more workers let's open
another Branch I I think that's a deeper
concern here I think our mood is going
to become quite negative throughout this
and I I do hope that by at least being
aware of this that it's something that
we you know prepare for and have
Solutions in place for and
um but you know I think economic side
that there's absolutely nothing positive
to say
why aren't people talking about this Mom
this is a question I used to when I
started interviewing people I'd go to
demographers and some people in the
press and that's the exact question I
would ask them
um I think it's part I think we covered
a little bit earlier the idea that this
is it's not a dramatic problem it's a
background problem and then you've
rightly identified the environment and
it sounds like a good thing and yeah we
used to be two billion people and some
people want to see us go down to one
billion
um
it's it's a problem we don't really
notice one day to another you know we we
wake up you know each day and today's
pretty much like yesterday you know
nothing really changes that much
this is a problem that's
slow to develop
but it's like this trap because once
you're in it you've lost the number of
potential parents to ever take you out
of Japan right now
um well it's been losing population for
10 or more years it was 127 million
we're down several million on that
pound can never effectively go back up
to those rates anytime The Next Century
or more because there's so few young
people that have children so we're
looking at at best Japan probably
stabilizing I don't know the number but
it might be 60 65 million at best
so from I I
a 120 120 million so we're yeah we're
that's realistic
um and that's if birth rates go back up
to a replacement level but they're not
you know so we're on this downward
spiral in in Japan and uh it's one of
the reasons I've chosen to live here I I
moved here through researching this
project five years ago
I think if Japan doesn't solve this
problem
um it's it's gonna be very worrying for
a lot of other nations because you know
it's a it's one of the world's
wealthiest Nations it's facing this
problem Direct on right now there's a
lot of awareness and in Japan by the way
people are talking about this this is on
the media now almost daily
it's gotten to that point and it will
get to that point in other countries too
so
um you know I I think Japan is an
opportunity to show the world how to
turn this around but I'm not seeing
anything that they're doing right now
despite lots of ideas I I have any real
confidence in what are the ideas when it
comes to policies the ones that are
useless and your ideas for what you
think would be most effective
well when you take Japan the blame here
is on work-life balance people work
um horrendous hours here
um pay time off you know one week a year
and a few extra days
um you know working to 11 pm would not
be uncommon at all
and the belief is that that needs to
change and it probably does of course it
does that that that's a horrendous Life
to Live uh working that way for for
anybody
but the idea that you know reducing
working hours and adding kindergarten
spaces and child care encouraging people
uh to move out of Tokyo that's something
now you're you're going to be giving us
some of money if you'll move out of the
city to somewhere more rural these are
all interesting things they may from
um past examples of this change the
birth rate very slightly but you're
talking about rounding errors and what
usually happens uh when you launch an
incentive like this there is an uptick
in the birth rate for one two years and
then it goes down but goes down lower
than it was because all you've done is
encourage people who are going to have a
second or third child anyway or start a
family sometime soon there's a pull
forward effect or let's do it now and
take advantage of this so really I think
it's
um fair to say that any scheme to
encourage people to have babies for
financial reasons alone uh hey look
you're asking people who are on the
career path building a career having
gone through all of this education or
everything prepared to kind of take an
early step out of that to start a family
so some will but Society itself needs to
be re-engineered this isn't about
tinkering with with systems like that my
own belief if I can share with you the
the optimism I do get is
when I talk about this
to younger people who have no idea that
life is these challenges I think young
people trust us people are a little bit
older than them in my case a lot older
that kind of we have you know prepared
this path for them that you know there's
this college path and then you're going
to start your career and then you're
gonna meet someone and you're gonna have
a family and the path is just they're
waiting for you
young people don't know about this
uncertainty they don't know that in many
countries now and across the
industrialized World a third or up to 40
45 in some countries of people are
childless and the majority vast majority
is unplanned childlessness
when you talk to young people about this
you can see the look in their eyes and
the dialogue with each other and I think
because of this problem there's going to
be fewer and fewer people to you know
for companies to hire I think
corporations government will have to
listen to Young People more to say what
is it that that you want and um I my
real belief is that people do want
families enough
to want to re-engineer the education
path the career path so they can do both
you know and that that's where you know
I I get my optimism from
and at the moment in the world 70 of
countries are already past this Tipping
Point that you're talking about yes yes
you know with India Bangladesh moving in
the past couple of years below
replacement level it's it's 70 and
really the only uh part of the world now
is sub-Saharan Africa with what we
consider High birth rates but in
sub-Saharan Africa
um since 1980
families of average are having one less
child every 15 years
so you know it's six and that's going
down to five and then it's time four and
if you plot that out you know by 2050
sub-Saharan Africa will be at
replacement level so we can see the same
Trend happening there's uh you know
sub-Saharan Africa is on the same roller
coaster as the rest of us but you know
in the rare car and
um we have to understand that
um there are a lot of young people in
Africa they will have children it's
natural Africa's population is going to
explode because there's so many young
people that will happen in fact to be
honest with you I see Africa as the
future I think there's a huge potential
in business and when we are all going
through I think the negative challenges
from birth rate decline in the
industrialized world people in Africa
are going to be going through what we
went through 50 years ago this economic
boom and
um you know I certainly um you know I I
I I I would love in future to spend more
time there because I can see that you
know that positivity in the faces of
people there and I I think people don't
understand this that you know the
quality of life happiness in Africa uh
for most people it is really quite high
and getting better all the time
Stephen I absolutely adore your work it
feels very serendipitous that we've
ended up uh crossing paths with each
other especially given my current pet
Obsession I really want to help what can
I do I'm happy to do what I can to help
you get whatever it is out there what is
it that I can do you've got an offer
from me you don't need to necessarily
say it now but you can call in the favor
at any time that you want I really want
to help you with this
well uh I I would be so honored because
I already recognized from your passion
and your deeper understanding than my
own in terms of you know dating in terms
of how people find their Partners
um what you're focused on is really the
the linchpin of ultimately trying to
find a way through uh what we're going
through I'd love to work with you my own
work it took me seven years to do the
research and make the documentary that's
the easy part
um I've created
um something called birthgap.org
um my plan is to have discussion groups
to have local meetups to have
information to have videos uh globally
on this topic and I'd love to invite you
more than once to come along and debate
and discuss this matter
um particularly with younger people be a
great great pleasure to to have you on
birthcap.org consider it done where can
people go if they want to learn more
about this the first half of the film is
available on YouTube I don't know where
the second half of the film is available
what's going on with that
yeah it's in three parts actually
um the first part really is is the why
why is this happening part two is you
know what are the consequences both
personally and for societies and then
part three is well what's happening in
the rest of the world and where we go to
Africa and spend more time in India and
Latin America uh you're right part one
is on birthgap.org and it's on YouTube
um I put it out there because I think
people need to understand you know what
what's happening uh Parts two and parts
three uh I am making a decision as to
whether those are going to go on some
streaming services
um right now we're working through them
what I don't want uh is to do a
traditional deal where I sign away all
the rights to this so someone else owns
and distributes it and decides to Market
it promote it or not my passion is these
documentaries are be available to
Educators globally at lower no cost
and I'm trying to work through kind of
the licensing agreements on how that
might look so birthgap.org people can
come and can find out what the latest
status on those but I'm sure in the next
few months we'll be explaining and if
anybody really wants to see Parts two
and part three I'm still looking for
some people to review those and give
feedback so I'll be delighted if anybody
uh just connect with me directly through
birthcap.org
Steven Show Ladies and Gentlemen I very
very much appreciate your work I can't
wait to keep in touch uh everybody needs
to go and check this out it's the end
the tail end of the big problem and the
big problem is pretty big so thank you
so much for coming on today mate I can't
wait to keep in touch
thank you Chris I appreciate it so much
thank you
so then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]